joining me today is the host of the
relatable podcast a speaker a
commentator and a cat person
Allie Stuckey welcome to the report
thank you for having me
all right Stuckey I have wanted you in
the studio for quite I'm so glad to be
here it is good to have you here but we
got I got two bones to pick just have to
do with cats number one person what's
going on she's so sweet I love dogs I
have a dog she's a rescue I have two
cats cats are just they're cool and
they're easy they don't need that much
of your time that much of your attention
I travel a lot like you do and so it's
nice to just be able to leave the cat's
but you got to put a dog in a kennel you
got to pay a bunch of money they need
your time they need your attention they
need to go outside cats are cool they
don't really want to hang out with they
are plotting to kill you most of the day
you're looking at you that they could
lunge at you at any moment a stereotype
that I would expect someone on the left
to make it's not true you have to take
cats by their individual personalities
and not categorize them look at how you
just used identity politics against me
just right right it applies to the
animal kingdom - I just needed you to
know
all right that's number one I'm just
gonna have to agree to disagree on cats
and dogs number two for about two years
I had the number one Praeger you video
why I left the left sorry then you came
in there you took number one away from
me but actually I don't know if you know
this as if don't ask did you see
somebody else
I don't even so we need to get them in
here now we have a bone to pick with
them yeah I actually can't remember who
was or what even the topic was I was
like I don't even want to know I don't
even want to know but you you was what
was the title of it was masculinity I
think it was like make men masculinity
or something like that so I guess that
was a hot topic that people really
wanted to hear about I mean it was so
fun to make obviously you've made
prettier you video too but I didn't
really anticipate it being one of those
viral videos I kind of just thought okay
most people in general agree with me but
the vitriol of course that I got you
just
you're continually surprised by some
people on the Left who are so opposed to
what are very traditional ideas so yeah
all right well we're going to talk about
some of those traditional ideas we'll
toss talked about masculinity and me too
and a whole bunch of other stuff called
for people that don't know you yeah
where'd you come from what's going on
here yes so I started in this whole kind
of political I won't even say media
field but kind of about three and a half
years ago so fall of 2015 I was working
in PR I graduated from college in 2014
PR social media just had kind of your
normal agency job but in fall of 2015 I
lived in a college town Athens Georgia
and I looked around did the friends that
I had both in college and out of college
had no idea what was going on in the
election it was the primaries and I
thought these are really smart people
and a lot of them are conservative in
their values and yet they seem to be
touting these progressive views when it
comes to politics and they really have
no idea what's going on and so I really
just kind of had a random idea when I
was driving one day called my mom and I
said you know I think I want to tell
sorority girls why they should vote in
the primaries because they seem so
apathetic I feel like I can talk to this
crowd because I was a story girl about a
year before that and so I created this
it really was a nonpartisan presentation
for for college students for why they
should vote in the primaries and I
started reaching out to add the sorority
presidents and you can find that
information online I just said can I
please come I want to speak for free
it's gonna be nonpartisan I just want to
tell you guys why you should vote in the
primaries and it works I mean I started
speaking to some of these groups and
then I started getting it asked by other
organizations on and off campus to come
speak and then from that I started a
blog and that was called the
conservative millennial ditched the
nonpartisan thing pretty quickly and
then after a few months of doing that I
started making videos and that's kind of
when it took off so and of 2016
beginning of 2017 is when it probably
officially became a career I started
working at the blaze and then that
changed to I moved to see our TV that's
where I started my podcast and that was
the beginning of 2018 yes I'm getting my
ears confused
20:18 that I started the podcast so
still speak still commentate I still
write still do a lot of the same things
I was doing three and a half years ago
it's just involved into a full-time
thing yeah
pretty sweet when you start doing
something and next thing you know it's
become something great not bad Wow do
you come from a political family or
anything did you care about all tics
before this or was that just your wake
up when you realize nobody knows what
they're talking about at college I would
say both and mostly mostly the second
one I I grew up in
I wouldn't say was an a political home I
knew we were conservatives and I knew we
liked the the earliest president that I
really remember his George W Bush and I
was really young during 9/11 and I
remember the patriotism that my parents
showed and that we were supposed to show
I knew we were supporting george w bush
and we kind of grew up watching fox news
but politics it wasn't a discussion that
we had at the dinner table necessarily I
just knew the values that we had my
parents out were entrepreneurs they came
from very poor families in Arkansas they
had no money when they got married they
were 19 and 20 and they really went from
nothing and then built a business and
built a life for my brothers and for me
that was so much better than the ones
that they had and so the idea of freedom
of entrepreneurship of not having a cap
on your potential was just always really
attractive to me so there was never a
time in college high school even as a
rebellious teenager that I was like you
know more government control actually
sounds really good it just it just never
never occurred to me that that would
lead to a better life I just always
loved the entrepreneurial spirit and the
idea of the American Dream that my
parents embodied so as more of those
values rather than talking about
politics my dad did become a state
representative when I was in college I
think it was 2012 and so yeah that
probably spurred some interest I started
probably getting more knowledgeable and
more informed about actually what was
going on but yeah I would say it's more
a lifelong value building thing and then
by the time I graduated college I was
like oh my gosh I feel like our nation
is kind of at a crisis how does religion
play a role in that it plays a huge it
plays a huge role you know we hear a lot
especially from people on the left
that your religious view should have
have no impact on what you believe
politically well that's just a false
idea of religion and a false idea of
your faith if your faith is the center
of your life which religious people
believe that it should be and it's going
to affect everything it's going to
affect all of your values it's going to
affect probably how you vote and it's
going to affect that the things that you
believe in politically and the way that
you think that the country should go and
so being not only a born-again Christian
but also a Protestant Christian having
roots in even the Protestant Reformation
and how that kind of affected the the
movement of the West towards freedom and
towards individual liberty I think has
certainly been a legacy that was passed
down to me and it all just it all has
always made sense I wish I had like a
better journey story of changing my mind
but the idea of individual liberty and
human dignity and all of the rights that
come with that it just it just always
made sense the stories that come from a
little more of an evolution that they
involve more violence and pain and for a
good story yeah they make for a good
book yeah
perhaps meaning so when you got into the
online world and started posting videos
podcasts thing and all that were you
shocked it's sort of the tenor and the
way people talk about these things and
all that well you know when I first
started when I first started the blog
and then I started doing videos I mean
one I had no money no backers no idea
what I was doing and I mean the first
videos that I did are in my living room
I have no makeup on no light and using
my phone look ridiculous got no views
whatsoever and so it was after I
persisted for a little bit sometimes I
look back and I'm like why did you even
persist no one was telling you to but
you did and then it's really the first
time that you get any kind of attention
or affirmation that you also see the
other side of it that you also see the
negativity when you're just doing it
kind of for yourself and for the few
people that follow you you're like this
is great everyone loves me but three
people that follow me all love me my
parents and my husband
love what I do this is great but then as
soon as something kind of blows
as they say you see the negative side of
it and you realize okay people don't
just disagree with you they really hate
you and they really think that you're a
bad person especially if you espouse any
kind of faith that immediately comes
into question if you disagree with them
and that was hard I mean I used to focus
on the comments a lot you have to stop
doing that though it's so unhealthy so
that's kind of that's changed over the
past few years definitely but yeah I
think the hatred threw me for a loop at
first yeah well it just sort of comes
and you don't really know what to do and
then at some point I think I've come
around to the place where it's like the
more I get I'm like oh I must be doing
something right yeah because people used
to lie about what I was saying and I
didn't like that now they actually quote
me and I'm like oh wow this is actually
great this mud must be feel like when
you made it I think it was actually you
that tweeted the other day some article
by right-wing watch was that you and
yeah they they did an article on me not
that long ago - they quoted something
that I said at CR TV and of course
everything looks like it's some hip
piece but then I read it and like that's
what I what I said it was the one of the
first ones I was like this is an actual
basically an honest piece great they
were really quite as what did you
exactly I'm like if people think that's
crazy I'm totally fine with that yeah
but like you said don't lie about don't
lie about what I'm saying yeah is it
unique to be a woman in this space use a
little identity politics here I thought
Republicans in the right I thought they
hate women
yeah listen to women don't they
subjugate women yes I just like being
subjugated but I am wearing shoes and so
I am against that part of it no I I've
never I've never really understood that
argument I guess if you equate women's
rights to abortion and to this mythical
gender wage gap that needs to somehow be
filled by the government if you equate
women's rights to that and women's
empowerment to that then sure I guess
the left is the only place for women but
if you believe in entrepreneurship if
you believe in the market place if you
believe that women have the potential
and the dignity that a man has and the
potential to do everything that a man
does but in a way at least as far as her
career goes and leadership goes then I
don't see why you wouldn't be a
conservative unfortunately we do have a
PR problem
on the right and I voted for president
Trump but president Trump doesn't really
help the rights case when it comes to
women not just because the things he
said and done with women but also I
think a lot of moms especially hear him
talk hear him at his rallies he's got a
little bit of a of a mouth and they're
like I don't you know I don't really
want my kids listening to that that's
not who I want my kids to be I wouldn't
marry someone like that and so I do
think that he makes it a little bit
difficult sometimes to make the case is
that the odd catch-22 of almost
everything Trump does because we talked
about this briefly right before we
started where it's like the policies
pretty much make sense and if you can
remove that from the tweets or the
person it's like he's actually had a ton
of high-level women totally in the
administration if you care if that's
what you're looking at yeah it just
makes it more difficult I think that
you're able to do it but when the left
is such a monopoly on media megaphones
when they have a monopoly on Hollywood
they have a monopoly on academia I won't
say monopoly but they're controlling a
lot of the messaging that comes out and
they're they're good at PR they're good
at the emotionalism that not to be
sexist but appeals to a lot of women and
so you hear the rhetoric of Trump is
putting kids in cages and he grabs women
by the genitals and you're a woman
you're like I can't vote for that I
can't do that and so in order to
separate some of the lies from the truth
and separate the things that Trump has
said from the good things that he's done
for men and women you have to think and
you have to go step further you have to
do your own research and a lot of people
male or female just don't want to do
that when you can read a headlines by
just swiping your thumb why are you
gonna take the time to actually click on
an article and then double check it and
make sure that it's right it's just
harder to be a conservative for that
very reason takes more effort how do you
cut through the clutter I mean that's
one of the things that especially when I
go to college is that kids ask me all
the time like how do you actually figure
out what's true yeah cuz reading all of
these articles it's like I mean we know
because they write them about us and
then it's like well I know what lies
that we're in there so what else what
else are they lying to us about oh you
really have to try to go to the source
if you can if they said that someone
says something you have to actually go
to the actual quote or the actual video
I mean a perfect example of this is when
President
just the other day the the clip of him
saying are allegedly saying that asylum
seekers were animals was circulating
from Britain yeah it was deceptively
edited and so in order for you
someone like chrissy teigen who tweeted
about it and said that you know he's
awful okay in order for you not to
believe chrissy teigen
in order for you to not believe the
tweet that she quote tweeted and hear in
several democratic candidates by the way
yes also so it's not just hollywood
celebrities even though they know he
wasn't just to be very clear here he was
not saying that animals he was
specifically talking about ms-13 which
is a totally appropriate description of
them but in order to realize that that's
a lie you have to jump through a lot of
Hoops I mean because say I'm someone on
the Left I say I'm someone in the middle
and I see Dave Rubin or Ben Shapiro to
say that's not really what he said well
why should I believe you anymore so you
have to go to the actual source you have
to go to actual reporting it's more
effort that's something that you and I
are probably willing to do because we
know the game that they're playing but a
lot of people just don't know but I also
think that's why people are turning away
in especially young people from
mainstream media and from talking heads
and listening to podcasts where there's
conversations and when there's dialogue
where there's nuance and where people
are willing to say you know I don't know
that much about this here's what both
sides are saying you hardly ever see
that on the news so I think I think
that's part of it it's a change in the
media landscape yeah where do you think
Trump fits in I try not to do that much
about Trump in general but since you
brought him up yeah where do you think
he fits in with sort of the future of
conservatism then yes I can sense a
little push and pull the key on him yeah
I mean I voted for him and I think I'll
vote for him again it's mostly because I
voted for him in 2016 mostly because
lesser of two evils then I didn't think
that he was going to lead very
conservatively I mean especially
pro-life is a huge issue for me he had
just a few years earlier said he was
pro-choice he didn't seem to emulate any
of the conservative or Christian values
that I hold in my life
but then I looked at Hillary Clinton and
I looked at how I felt like the country
was torn apart by Barack Obama over the
past eight years and I was like okay
someone who is going to probably
advocate for legislation and surround
himself with people that align
more with my values or someone who I
think is diametrically opposed policy
wise to everything I believe so I chose
him and I think I would choose him again
because again I not that I would ever
vote Democrat and I've never been on the
left but if I were say I were a centrist
I would be looking over to the left in
saying okay this guy don't like what he
says don't like his personality I think
he's too brash and sometimes he doesn't
make any sense he calls Tim Cook Tim
Apple okay yeah like he's a little
embarrassing but then I look at people
who are advocating friendly term
abortion open borders and socialism and
I'm like I like my babies and my private
property I think I'm gonna stick with
Trump and so yeah I'm even more so in
that camp because I am a conservative
and I do care about the future of the
country and I hate socialism so of
course I'm gonna vote for him again and
I think that's how a lot of people feel
so sometimes a hard case to make yeah
that's how I see it I mean it's like if
you guys could just not be that bananas
then the refugees wouldn't do any even
you but you just can't not be completely
insane
well sometimes I wonder if it's a
strategy are they taking us to the nth
degree are they taking us to the the
most crazy Marxism that they can
actually take us are they taking us -
for example medicare-for-all
just so we'll get on board with
healthcare for all are they taking us to
open borders just so we'll be okay with
abolishing ice are they taking us to you
know killing babies outside of the womb
to where we can say okay as long as it's
limit to the second trimester because I
mean I don't think that's going to work
but I do wonder are you guys pushing us
to the limits so we'll settle for
something a little bit less but that's
still liberal I don't know yeah I mean I
suppose I suppose that could well you
know I don't know what the answer is but
I suppose they could be do I mean Trump
does a little of that right take out
something really far and then you come
in I mean that's what negotiations are
about
yes I don't know but watching these guys
go off the deep end has been quite
something and I so I mentioned to you a
couple days ago on on Twitter so I
you've been hitting aoc pretty hard and
I think your arguments you never attack
her personally you always go for policy
or for the the context of what she's
talking about yeah tell me a little bit
about why you're not thrilled with aoc
well we hear a lot of people in the last
saying Oh
Oh see gets to y'all she's really
getting into y'all and she really
bothers you and I'm like yes she really
does I'm not even gonna pretend like she
doesn't especially bother me she
especially bothers me because she is
representative of Millennials which she
isn't really but she's representative of
the stereotypes of Millennials and she's
a woman and so she is claiming to
represent all Millennials in all women
and she is espousing and saying
everything that is so diametrically
opposed not only to what I believe in
but what is good for America and also
like she just says dumb things just dumb
it's not that
okay she's crazy like I think Bernie
Sanders is crazy but I think he's
probably smart like he can make a pretty
good argument she just isn't good she's
not even good at fulfilling her own
arguments and I think it's her
it's the hypocrisy to of saying well no
one has any legitimate concerns with me
no one has any legitimate criticism I'm
going to pull this random tweet from
this person with ten followers and say
well this is all of the right making fun
of my shoes this is all they've got well
no there's been a lot of people asking
you for a dialogue and debate and to
discuss ideas and policies and you
refuse to that's what bothers me yeah so
what do we do about that because the the
energy of the media the focus so much of
it is on her I agree I don't think she's
particularly bright I think she has
handlers that at times yeah are writing
her look she's not writing most of these
tweets yes maybe she types them out but
it's very clear if you listen to her
speak the way she speaks and her
understanding of information is very
loose and then in in Twitter form she
knows all these things about history and
policy and all of these things and the
idea that she wrote the Green Deal or
any of that stuff now it's just all
nonsense but what do you do if so much
of the energy is focused there which I
you know I think we're in agreement it's
dangerous yeah how do you move that if
she won't debate yeah I think that all
you can do is advocate for your own
policies and idea is the best way that
you can and yes of course to call out
her lies and say this is why it's a lie
I mean you might not convince everyone
but maybe there is one person who
thought that her tweet was often looked
at what you said and said okay well
maybe now I am starting to see a pattern
of not just her but people like her that
used ID
politics and use this victimhood
narrative someone like Ilhan Omar as
well to say oh you can't criticize me
I'm seeing that a lot maybe her
credibility comes into question so I do
think that's important I think it's
important to keep it above for it as
much as we can with the criticisms now
I'm not necessarily good at that like
sometimes I just want to all fails oh
yeah and I don't I don't want to call I
mean I don't think I ever go for
anything super personal or ad hominem
but there are times where I just want to
be like this girl's an idiot she's an
idiot girl and I don't think that's
that's probably just to call myself out
I don't think that's the most productive
thing to do we should probably say why
she's wrong but someone who I think is
actually trying to play her same game
it's a little bit different because he's
older and he's a man but Dan Crenshaw is
using social media to his benefit to
actually talk about what's going on in
Congress say here's the legislation I'm
trying to get passed here's what the
Democrats are doing here's the
back-and-forth fight we have hardly any
transparency in Congress from the right
we don't have a young representative
that saying okay this is what you're
hearing here's what's actually happening
AOC is trying to do that but you do have
someone like Dan Crenshaw who is trying
to do it on our side and I think that's
important what do you think is the goal
of this new crop of Democrats like do
you like to me they genuinely want to
change every fundamental law and every
fundamental philosophy that has
underpinned this country for over 200
years
really it sounds alarmist it sounds
conspiratorial but I think they're
deeply unpro and it's very sad for me as
we talked about right before we started
it's like this ain't the party of JFK
anymore
right it was one thing when we just
disagreed on policy it's another thing
when we disagree on patriotism it's when
we disagree that fundamentally America
was founded on good ideas maybe you
don't like the founder founding fathers
maybe you don't even like that they own
slaves
maybe you think that America has a bad
history we can probably agree on that
that America doesn't have a perfect
history but that's not agreeing on basic
constitutional values of individual
liberty of the rates that are endowed to
us by our Creator that creates a whole
other host of problems we have not more
complicated disagreements between this
new crop but more fundamental
disagreements more simple disagreements
that we
ever had before that's what makes them
so frustrated and people like me like us
who care about American values and are
down with the Constitution it's really
kind of mind-boggling like we don't even
know where to take their arguments
sometimes but when you look at what's
coming out of the academia I mean all
this postmodern garbage it kind of makes
sense I mean they've been taught that
America is this imperialist aggressor
and everywhere boots have been on
American boots have been on the ground
evil has spread and white nationalism
has spread that's what they're learning
you're like okay I can see where they
got that it's sad because it's
inaccurate but I think that's kind of
where it's coming from and that's what
they're promulgating yeah are there
parts of the right that you're not happy
with definitely I mean if the OL trade
is even still a thing I feel like it's
kind of had its heyday I literally pray
that it's had of course I don't like
them I think they're a bunch of internet
trolls there are people also who think
that the world the West is going to be
won back through memes I don't think
there's anything wrong with me anything
wrong with that but I don't think that's
primarily where the with where the
battle is fought and then I do get
frustrated with people who can't ever
criticized Trump when he says things for
example and this was a while ago saying
okay we'll take away their guns and then
due process or something like that or
where they can't refute him on trade
they can't push back at him at all or
they try to paint him into like this
almost demigod Savior that bothers me
because okay let's not pretend that he's
Ronald Reagan he might have even done
better things than Ronald Reagan in a
lot of ways but let's not pretend that
who he is as a man is Ronald Reagan that
he represents all of our conservative
values I think it's okay to say you know
what as a Christian I don't really agree
with a lot of the things that he says a
lot of the things that he's done
I still like his policies but I'm just
gonna be honest I don't love everything
that he's done the people that will not
say that that bothers me I just don't
get it do you think that there's like
sort of a sickness around the cult of
personality related to our politicians
the way we talk about them and think
about them I mean so you could take that
with Trump from certain people you know
the certain just diehard mag of people
who would never find fault and you could
take that with the obsession with oh
there's better with this
shirt rolled up standing on a table and
skateboarding and just the way we talk
about them like they're all celebrities
or that that they have the wherewithal
yeah fix all our problems it all
actually feels gross to me like politics
feels very gross to me for someone that
talks about it as much as I do yeah I
don't know if it's because it's gotten
so dramatized that it almost feels like
our favorite soap opera you know how
someone has a character they just love
and can do no wrong they're like I'm
fighting for this person in this show
it's almost that are our politics have
become so celebra ties which really
almost started with Barack Obama and so
dramatized that people have picked their
favorite characters and they feel like
they have to pick one and there's
there's no way yeah there's no way that
they're gonna pick the other one but I
also think it has to do with the fact
that they see their enemy as so bad as
so crazy as so radical and the left is
beating up on Trump so much and so
unfairly that they they I think they're
honestly thinking and maybe with good
intentions why would I pile on that sure
maybe I don't like some of the stuff
that he does but we never hear any of
the good that he does so I'm gonna be a
part of the group that talks about the
good that he does and not the bad so
maybe maybe those intentions are pure
yeah so I I do agree with that I think
that there's a certain set of people
that think well wait a minute this guy
is relentlessly getting attacked and
lied about less reinvestigations and
everything else so when he says
something like to me the one that you
hit on will take away the guns first and
then the due process to me that probably
is the worst thing that he has said in
in the two-plus years and I could see
why a decent person that would know that
that's wrong wouldn't go crazy about it
because a he probably was probably just
like sloppy language maybe right yeah
maybe but be it's like everyone's
attacking the guy constantly like cut
him some slack there's a danger of that
too yeah and I think it's that they look
at his actions they keep saying or I
should say we we look at his actions
like do I think that he is ideologically
pro-life do I think he really cares
about abortion probably not now maybe
he's been awakened to like a lot of
people have with the New York law and
the Virginia bill that didn't get passed
and said okay that's really bad but I
don't really care what
personally thinks about abortion because
he's been a pro-life advocate and I
think that's a good thing and I want him
to advocate for the things that I
believe in and I always knew and I was
always pretty confident in the fact that
even if he's not an ideologue which I
think we all knew that he wasn't he was
going to surround himself by people that
would push the values and the policies
that conservatives believe in and that's
nowadays that's really all I care abouts
almost all I wouldn't say all but that's
most of what I care about enough to get
my vote so is that the irony I guess for
Christian conservatives is that you
needed a guy that was gonna do play a
dirty game and and maybe you couldn't
get Romney or McCain yeah they tried it
the other way like those guys weren't
gonna play in such a way because it's
not just that you're fighting the
candidate you're also finding a media
establishment and the colleges and all
that that's not how I thought of it
because I didn't vote for him in the
primaries and like him in the primaries
I actively talked about not voting from
the primaries and I honestly didn't
understand